hi everybody
program exists and many other generally
they would be here tonight founding the
inspiration behind this but it's a
pleasure to introduce reading tonight
this fall he's a historian theorist of
digital media and the senior lecturer
and communications at the University he
also works as a curator an educational
program for the Anthropocene at the
house there were two in this and from
last year's that we've had the pleasure
of getting to never any here first of
all as a member of the existed reading
Sawyer seminar Mellon story or seminar
and he create about me in French
and then that also has as the photo of
this this fall also has a visiting
professor
[Applause]
so thank you for that very generous
introduction it's a real pleasure to be
speaking here at the Humanities Center
where throughout this semester I've been
having some of the most exciting
intellectual dialogues really of my
entire academic career the topic tonight
was partially selected in relationships
to some themes we've been discussing
here
one being the relationship of science to
the humanities another being the
question of something like the nonhuman
right both of which I see is being
themes that were more or less explored
in a particularly decisive way in in
French post-war French thought
particularly in connection with
cybernetics so my remarks are attempting
to contribute to that conversation we've
been having but also to elaborate on
some conversations I've been having in
parallel with my colleagues in the
excessive screens project with Francesca
with whom we share a very particular
interest in semiotic s-- so I'm
rethinking some things I've said about
cybernetics in the past according to
some of his suggestions and again this
also intersects again with the
conversation rüdiger and I have been
having
about Hitler and technical media which I
never seem to reach the end of Saturday
thank you mostly for allowing me to be
part of this conversation and
reciprocate in a small way in December
1948 Dominique de barro reviewed MIT
mathematician Norbert wieners recently
published book cybernetics or control
and communication in the animal in the
machine for France's leading daily
newspaper Lu moaned with the term
cybernetics Wiener proposed to found a
new interdisciplinary science what
historian Jeffrey Bauer has termed a
universal science based on the premise
of common principles of communication
and feedback said to govern living
living beings social systems and
machines Wiener based the work largely
on his wartime studies of human machine
systems such as anti-aircraft firing
mechanisms he hoped that cybernetics
would become an umbrella discipline for
a variety of contemporaneous scientific
and technological advances such as
digital computing and information theory
from the technical side but also fields
such as anthropology sociology political
science which he thought had a kind of
systemic communicative underpinning that
can be explained by theories of
information de barro writing in Lemont
hailed cybernetics as a prophetic and
disturbing study that cast light on the
role mathematical analysis and computing
machines would be poised to play in the
future of world governance in view of
the tremendous scope that cybernetics
seemed to have for human culture he
suggested that quote perhaps it would
not be a bad idea for the teams at
present creating cybernetics to add to
the cadre of technicians who have come
from all horizons of science some
serious anthropologists and perhaps a
philosopher who has some curiosity as to
world matters
glass of water say it preemptively the
shape such an interdisciplinary cadre of
cybernetic researchers should take and
its meaning for the so-called human
sciences emerged as a theme of
remarkable and recurring interest in
post-war French thought over the course
of the next two and a half decades
spearheading the introduction of
cybernetic thought into the sciences of
man was French anthropologist Claude
levy shows around 1951 sought to
establish a cybernetics Research
Laboratory in Paris and subsequently
convened a cybernetics seminar that
counted mathematician Pierre chutes and
Berger mathematician thank you very much
so I moved to the topic of how it is
that the idea of an interdisciplinary
cadre of cybernetics researchers became
an enduring topic in post-war French
thought what's really a question that
people are returned to well into the 70s
right and the person who really put this
on the agenda in post-war France more
than anyone else was Claude lévi-strauss
right so first he attempts to set up a
cybernetic laboratory around 1951 he
never seems to get the funding for that
however he does set up a cybernetics
reading group was covertly funded by the
CIA he didn't know that and among its
participants were the mathematicians
shoots in berger and benoit mandelbrot
psychoanalyst Jacques Lacan linguist
émile benveniste and philosopher Jean
EEP elite in private and public settings
this influential community of
researchers asked how cybernetics and
it's conceptual cousins information
theory and game theory recast the
objects and agendas of the so called
human sciences these communication
theories provided a key point of
reference and debate over the
possibility of remaking the human
sciences along communicative models such
as those developed in cybernetics but in
close relationship to structural
linguistics which had a related agenda
so for researchers including michel
foucault on real effete michel ser
rollin bart Umberto Eco Jean Baudrillard
geo Deleuze and Felix Guattari there
emerged a kind of conceptual
entanglement of structural linguistics
with cybernetics based very much on how
levy shows set up the project of
structuralism and this entanglement
became an occasion for rethinking the
relationship to reforms in the human
sciences the status of the human
sciences in a relationship to a broader
array of post-war themes among them yet
industrialization decolonization mental
health and technocracy
so what I'm trying to really discuss it
is a kind of transition from the 1950s
up through the early 1970s where
cybernetics starts as a kind of model
for thinking through communication in
the human sciences but gradually itself
becomes an object of interrogation
itself become something subject to a
kind of critical historicize asian and
the thinking of what Derrida called
in Gromit ology quote the non fortuitous
conjunction of cybernetics and the human
sciences of writing end quote so within
this transition post were French
reflections on the on the rise of
scientific theories of communication
tended and this is with marked militancy
from the early 1960s onwards to
interrogate to interrogate the grounds
for the kinds of communicative Universal
isms advanced by cybernetics and
information theory they also sought to
think through what are the possibilities
what are the problematics that allow for
a kind of convergence of technical
scientific and humanistic theories of
communication so this became not simply
an opportunity but a problem for
reflection in its own right and part of
what enters me is this largely sets
apart the French reception of
cybernetics and the so called human
sciences from say its reception in Great
Britain or the United States where
people such as Gregory Bateson in the
United States working in psychotherapy
or Stafford beer working in management
and Great Britain sought to more or less
apply cybernetics all right to their
disciplines right whereas there was
really a kind of critical reflection on
what it meant that cybernetics was
convening or having a conjunction with
the human sciences in France and in so
doing I think something peculiar happens
right
the reason I'm really interesting this
is I seems to me that you know what we
sometimes call French Theory actually
secures a place for the human scientist
so to speak to reflect on what
communication is right by not simply
assimilating cybernetics into their
domain
but rather by coming to reflect on what
it means to have a convergence of these
disciplines they secure for I'm gonna
say again the so called human science is
a portion to speak on their own about
what communication might be the rise of
cybernetics and post-war French thought
owed much to the mediations of Russian
linguist Roman Jakobson
and Livy Stros who met during World War
2 under the auspices of the Kolob
there's altitude a francophone
university in exile hosted at the New
School for Social Research and funded by
the Rockefeller Foundation the founding
of the Kolob joined a humanitarian
mission to save researchers threatened
by national socialism to a longer term
epistemological strategy aimed at
reforming the human sciences in France
since the 1920s a network of
philanthropies linked to the Rockefeller
Foundation had sought to reform the
humanities and social sciences
internationally with a particular
emphasis on promoting synthetic research
programs that can join the softer human
sciences with technocratic projects of
social improvement in the United States
these efforts played a major part in the
rise of mass communications research in
the 1930s and 1940s and after World War
2 the founding of Communication Studies
in close relationship to technical
fields such as information theory and
cybernetics but efforts to enact similar
reforms in France had long faltered in
part doing - due to buying conceptions
of society technocracy and intellectual
inquiry that clashed between say the
models of the Rockefeller Foundation and
higher education in France all right so
the Rockefeller Foundation was
interested this is something I think can
interest us alright destroyed the
Rockefeller Foundation is partially
about the rise of external funding third
party funding for the sciences right and
a kind of entrepreneurial model of
science that comes from private
foundations and
this model of kind of entrepreneurial
science did not immediately fit so well
with what was going on in the French
human sciences in the 20s and 30s but
there is also a strong resistance of the
Rockefeller Foundation to for example
the type of social science being
practiced in France this would the key
moment for this would be in the 1920s
there's an effort to found a so called
caesium sexy home of the occult practic
dis Alta - to sense a School of Social
Sciences in Paris under the direction
ship under the directorship of Marceau
most right and this ultimately collapses
because there's this kind of holistic
synthetic approach the definition of
society that most is advocating that
really clashes with the type of much
more positivistic practical research the
Rockefeller Foundation is promoting now
the occult leave this oughta tude is
founded very much with the idea of
overcoming some of these problems that
they ran into when they tried to promote
particular have social science in France
in the 20s and 30s in the years after
World War two veterans of the school
including Jakob s'en and Livi's rose
tapped a net worth a jockelson stays in
the United States
Larry Strauss and many other researchers
go back to France and they tap a network
of financing opportunities and social
networks linked to the Rockefeller
Foundation that privileged methods
originating and communication
engineering such as cybernetics and
information theory part of this relates
to the fact that the director of Natural
Sciences at the Rockefeller Foundation
Warren Weaver oversaw the development of
information theory and cybernetics
during the 1940s as part of wartime
research so in France living Stros acts
as a conduit or acted as a conduit for
negotiations with American foundations
that facilitate the funding finally of a
successful caesium sex Yule this is this
has funding from the Rockefeller
Foundation but also from the Ford
Foundation drawing on the network's
cultivated in these years in the United
States during World War two Libby
Strauss begins to promote structural
linguistics structural anthropology and
cybernetics as complement complementary
methods of Investigation they mutually
conceive of language and
society as systems of communication his
first major work in this mold was the
brilliant but rather contentious
rereading of Moses essay on the gift it
was an introduction to this book here
let me show Sri Reed's most as essay on
the gift as a kind of proto cybernetics
study of the communicative foundations
of society where most had emphasized the
difficulty of gift-giving in primitive
society that is to say its organization
biological rivalry it's essential
imbalances leading towards vast social
disruption and the impossibility of
negating the disruptiveness of
communication through say technocratic
or actuarial means maybe Strauss argue
that gift-giving provided a mechanism
for resolving social conflicts or
tensions it's a very different sort of
emphasis and he validated this in part
by references to the mathematical theory
of communication the founding text of
information theory that was co-authored
by Bell Labs engineer Claude Shannon as
well as the director of the Natural
Sciences at the Rockefeller Foundation
Warren Weaver working with the writings
of Roman Jakobson who had reinterpreted
sorceress binary long parol pair in the
cybernetic terms of code and message
Levy shows began in the 1950s to lay the
found work or the groundwork for
displacing the preoccupations of
existentialism and phenomenology with a
set of social scientific concepts linked
to cybernetics so function code system
and rules these were very much the
preoccupation of the communication
engineer and to a certain extent that
kind of technocratic preoccupations
you're more likely to find at the
Rockefeller Foundation cybernetics and
information theory devised for the
purposes of recuperating or stabilizing
communications and technical media
became exemplars of a new mathematical
method that could recuperate disorder
noise and contingency in human social
systems and
I wouldn't want to overemphasize the
point and say it's not as if cybernetics
produces structuralism or post-war
French structuralism right again this is
based in part my conversations about
having Francesco it provides a set of
suggestions right it's the set of
suggestions according to which one can
begin rethinking what exactly it is
human sciences Social Sciences are about
and according to which you can kind of
modernize traditions of social
scientific thought to give them a kind
of new technical allure that's suitable
to a kind of post-war industrial
industrializing France so Libby choses
meditation on the gift constitute a kind
of oblique reciprocation to the largesse
and hospitality of his American patrons
that is their largesse both towards
himself and towards French higher
education through that essay as well as
subsequent works including the
mathematics of man and his unpublished
public lecture towards a general theory
of communication Livy shows opened the
door to a vast rewriting of French
social scientific traditions in
alignment in alignment with new schools
of research associated with
communication engineering as was
underway in the United States right in
this way this structuralist is a
revolution and it's Thai society eggs
seem to be playing in France a role that
was being played in the United States by
Alexander bad last Roman Jakob sanur
Gregory Bateson in their efforts to come
up with a new interdisciplinary science
that would bridge the natural and Social
Sciences around models of communication
if successful levy Strauss's cybernetic
gambit not only would transcend
traditional opposition's between the
natural and human sciences it would also
open the doorway to a program of social
scientific collaboration that cut across
national and political boundaries of the
nascent Cold War and this is something
yokas and myself delivery shows
themselves is very explicit about right
that this can overcome tradition
political opposition's and when he's
critiqued in particular by French
Marxist for smuggling in a kind of
militaristic American research into
French Sciences he says well these these
critics they revealed themselves that
they don't really understand the
scientific foundations of this research
which is to say its neutrality now among
ladies roses interlocutors responses to
cybernetics fell into more or less two
general trends the first important but
slightly less interesting trend amounted
to us a rejection of cybernetics as
ill-suited or irrelevant to the sciences
man so for example in problem problems
in general linguistics benveniste a
participant in the cybernetics seminar
and a co-founder of post-war French
structural linguistics referred somewhat
disdainfully to linguists who in their
search for General Laws fell victim to
the lure of mathematize ation of
transcription devices these kind of
technical recording many of the sort
jakob son was using and quote recent
techniques like the theories of
cybernetics or information and quote in
his 1957 in 1958 lectures at the collège
de France maurice merleau-ponty
labeled cybernetics quote and extremely
materialist and an extremely idealist
thinking one that he said effectively
erred and turning machines into a kind
of science in their own right and then
applying knowledge from the machine onto
nature onto human beings and so that you
know the sense ideal idealist in the
sense that it's a kind of idealization
from machines but materialist in the
sense that it's kind of slavishly tied
to the mechanisms of machines so the
objections you find in both benveniste
and merleau-ponty
in fact echoed those of the young
American linguist Noam Chomsky who
famously demonstrated in 1957 and since
in syntactic structures that human
language was organized by a distinctly
human grammar that could not be
reproduced by state
mystical theories of communication right
language is not information it has among
other things our grammar in the cases of
these three thinkers cybernetics was in
effect quarantined by arguing for the
irreducibility of human language - the
rules of communication engineering in
this account an unbreachable wall
separated the dignity of human reason
from the mechanisms of industrial
information processing this analysis you
know in effect preserved for the human
mind a kind of super historical
integrity that was independent from
scientific and technological development
right so the machines themselves have a
set of historical developments but the
mind itself and language in particular
transcends these historical changes a
second more interesting response could
be found among leve choses interlocutors
Locka and i believe neither it's
important to notice imported the
propositions of cybernetics and
information theory wholesale into their
research instead they use the
suggestions of cybernetics to rethink
the specificity of their own
communicative objects for Lacan it's
psychoanalytic discourse for a palete
philosophical and poetical discourse but
in so doing the key is they allowed
cybernetics to begin restructuring their
objects and the mode of analysis that
tended to displace some of the hallmarks
of human reason right there's this kind
of entanglement underway here moreover
both welcomed cybernetics
transdisciplinary aims has an occasion
to rethink the boundaries of the human
sciences with a particular emphasis on
the role of Science in refashioning
knowledge of man and possibly man
himself what resulted was a kind of
delicate balancing act a refusal to
submit to the Imperial izing aims of
cybernetics but a fascination with the
potential of machine excite of
communications
to disrupt and even historicize naive
claims for human consciousness so let's
consider it first the case of Lacan like
merleau-ponty Martin Heidegger and
Chomsky but can't adamantly maintained
that language itself was not reducible
to code language he declared in his 1955
lecture the Freudian thing is not a code
and is not the same thing as information
end quote
Lacan also contrasted the focus and
information theory on removing
redundancies the practice of the
psychoanalyst so information theory
allows you to extract extra bits of
information from a transmission so you
can transmit it more effectively right
for 4.com psychoanalysis is partially
about finding peculiar redundancies
stuttering repetitions errors omissions
which themselves have some revelatory
power
according to the konk quote this is
highly instructive to us for what is
redundant as far as information is
concerned precisely with what plays the
part of resonance in speech for the
function of language is not to inform
but to invoke end quote
in this regard LeConte rejected
cybernetics assumption that language
could be modelled as a kind of neutral
technical or functionalist system that
was simply there to be streamlined and
rendered more effective but was quite
interesting is at the same time the
cause definition of the symbolic largely
elaborated in the course of his 1954 and
1955 lectures on the ego here we go I
don't actually use this quote but I
really like it so that's why I put it up
there his definition of the symbolic
elaborated in the course of this 1954
1955 seminar is closely modelled on
understandings of the symbolic as
machines were able to process it so in
the lecture Lacan declares for example
that man emerged from quote a play of
symbols a symbolic world within which
man was a decentered subject end quote
but this notion of the subject as
inscribed in highly-structured even
mathematically determined series while
it found inspiration the structural
linguistics of Jakob sin
I found instantiation in cybernetic and
computing machines working from the
premise that the most advanced work in
cybernetics information theory and
computing based on itself was based on
machines that could process symbolic
strings Lacan explained to his auditors
quote that the world of the symbolic is
the world of the Machine end quote and
what he basically says is highly
advanced machines process symbolic
strings but they said more or less aloof
from it whereas man himself finds
himself entangled in the system of
language and comes to recognize himself
and others through that that linguistic
mediation so the cosmos famous account
of the machine ik character of the
symbolic order is developed during the
course of that year's seminar
that's a year's lecture in the seminar
on the purloined letter now this lecture
found part of its inspiration in a pair
of machines that wore in fact designed
by Claude Shannon at Bell Labs as well
as his lab partner David Hager Berger
these were machines that essentially
played a guessing game described in the
Prolog later by Edgar Allan Poe
so Poe served describes a simple
guessing game of odds and evens where
the goal is to simply guess what your
partner is going to choose odds or evens
in the course of playing now as it
happens humans are very bad at
generating random numbers right they
can't make random choices so what
happened with Shannon and how the Barger
took this story took this example that
appears in Poe and they designed two
machines that could more or less predict
you know fifty five sixty percent
accuracy whether a human player is going
to choose odds or evens or in this case
plus or minus all right they publish on
this and what we're now it's not quite
clear Lacan receives this publication on
the on these two machines that can play
the game described
ground post story so these two machines
theatrically demonstrated how human
thought itself was pattern and
predictable and it provided an object
lesson in the relative ease with which a
machine could navigate symbolic order
and the relative difficulty that the
same tasks post for humans who found
themselves a mesh in the operations of
that symbolic order Lacan found in Cyr
those named this device here on the Left
evidence of human interactions as
structured by an impersonal and
non-subjective symbolic order in his
elaboration of these themes in the
seminar on the ProLiant letter he turns
the story into a kind of combinatorial
and topographic tale of how media in
this case a missive gone astray creates
symbolic chains among those who would or
would not have the letter so you see
you're a kind of highly delicate
relative ization of cybernetics a
refusal of many of the very crude
applications of it to human language but
also an attempt to rethink what humans
are up to according to I'm using
Francesco's word the suggestions of
cybernetics right this is all
interesting this all very important it
sets them apart for example at the very
least from merleau-ponty Chomsky is more
complicated but he'd also does something
that's much more interesting it's not
quite as elaborated that sort of sets
the stage for what ends up unfolding in
the course of the next I'd say 15 years
in post-war French thought right what do
you what Lacan does is he suggests that
there's actually a common historical
development that underpins
psychoanalysis and cybernetics and that
it's this common historical development
that provides insights into how and why
the two might have something to say to
one another so according to Norbert
Wiener cybernetics in the communication
sciences had developed from the rise of
the steam engine and thermodynamics
which ushered forth a new era of science
based on energetic relations of closed
systems that operated on statistical
principles so you have this shift with
thermodynamics with the steam engine
away from Newtonian make
annex towards a system of circulation
within which physical elements become
elements of communication in the Contin
alysus it was by means of this
transition away from mechanical
determination towards statistics that
the exact sciences took a step beyond
naive empiricism of the 19th century and
towards an understanding of objects as
produced through an economy of relations
more to the point for the history today
citing watt and the steam engine the
calm posited that this same shift
furnished Freud himself
with a concept of energy by which he
could rethink the human psyche as a
system of energetic relations for Lacan
so it seems the Freudian concept of the
libido had a relationship to the steam
engine that more or less parallel that
of statistical mechanics and the work of
Clark Maxwell in relationship to the
steam engine so you have a kind of
technological intervention innovation
that unlocks a new set of communicative
relations on which you can start
producing new types of science and will
accommodate later call a new subject of
science now he doesn't develop this as
fully as he might suggestions he leaves
kind of hanging in the course of his
seminar but these remarks set the stage
for the elaboration of a new kind of
tension between cybernetics and the
human sciences because now cybernetics
became part of a historical
transformation of the sciences to which
both cybernetics and the human sciences
were playing a part and what's also
quite significant is that as these kind
of suggestions from the Kahn are hanging
there in the air you also have the
development of molecular biology in
France you have the work of Jacques
Monod Francois Jacques cope and Andre
Michel wolf that effete effectively
tries to understand life under the
banner of genetics as a system of
information right and so here you start
to see a kind of bifurcation and
relationships to cybernetics and
post-war French thought
as late as 1968 Livi shows and Jakob
s'en could for example appear on French
television alongside Francois Jaco who
at this point actually won the Nobel
Prize for his research as part of a
broader discussion about whether or not
there might be some unification of the
sciences around communicative ideas
alright this is a very public debate but
you also have a parallel track where by
scholars such as Kang Jiyoung Foucault
ser and dari da begin asking the
question what would it mean for the
sciences to have a kind of theory of
communication that might itself also
include science itself right so instead
of simply applying it to the human
sciences it starts becoming the
questions of what a science might be in
a kind of era of communication theory
this problematic was elaborated in
particular detail in Jacques Derrida by
Jacques Derrida in his 1967 monograph of
grommit ology which among other things
situates his intervention against the
backdrop of the rise of cybernetics on
one hand the rise of molecular biology
on the other and he says that
particularly in the case of cybernetics
there's an attempt with the idea of
information to erase the distinctions
between say humans and machines between
life and the machine and he sees this as
a kind of attempt to kind of overcome
metaphysics right but he says this might
be the case but even if that's the case
this project would have to grapple with
the extent to which writing itself
already determined the history and
ethics of the European Sciences so what
he termed quote the non-virtuous
conjunction of cybernetics and the human
sciences unquote reflected these fields
belong to a common scientific tradition
determined by writing
if that conjunction reached a certain
hyperinflation in the post-war era as
dairy I suggested it did this related as
much to the quote practical methods of
information retrieval end quote that
were in the process of generalizing the
concept of message to include fields
such as biology and such as anthropology
and so because of this conjunction sure
driven in part by information Sciences
between the sciences of writing and
cybernetics the human sciences of
writing the practitioners of the human
scientists could not eyes they for
example did in the case of merleau-ponty
or even Chomsky speak with cool
indifference to the fact of cybernetics
they cannot simply reject it right but
rather the Human Sciences themselves
found found seemed to kind of a flicker
to have a certain uncertainty in the
face of these developments in these
challenges hence in this quote oh gosh I
put the wrong quote up on the page ok ok
he puts the Human Sciences in quotes in
the history of this conjunction because
the human science itself is starting to
fall under question
even as cybernetics itself is also
becoming a kind of conceptual problem
for reflection right and so this is part
here's the quote that I get to now this
is a part of a general reflection on
cybernetics as a reflection of what the
scientists are so Michel Foucault also
again speaking on television says in
1965 it can't be said of cybernetics or
the theory of information that is the
philosophy of the psychology of learning
just as one cannot say that what Lacan
or live across the philosophy of
anthropology or psychology
instead is a particular reflexive
relation of science to itself
so here you see this bifurcation where
you're gradually having a critical
interrogation not only of how the Human
Sciences could be transformed by
cybernetics right but also how science
itself must be transformed as part of
this process so against this backdrop
ambitions for semiology elaborated with
an enthusiasm by the likes of Livy Stros
rollin bart or AJ a grimace began to
confront increasingly what a such a
project would imply for science itself
particularly if science itself was
understood as a mode of writing a major
center for these reflections with the
Center for the Study of mass
communications founded in 1960 at the
cesium section of the occult practicas
oughta tude the center seem to realize
live east roses and the Rockefeller
Foundation's hopes to establish a center
of scientific experimental and empirical
communications research in France this
positioned the center at the
intersection of efforts to introduce
social science inter for the French
University such as it was conceived by
the Rockefeller Foundation as well as an
ongoing effort to reimagine their
traditional humane and literary arts in
an age of techniques and technology
through coursework conferences in the
center's in-house journal communications
researchers at the Center imaginably
intermingled the aspirations of American
empirical social science with French
structuralism and elements of Marxist
critique among the lecturers were
Rowland Bart as well as a host of
up-and-coming graduate students and
young lecturers including literary
critics kristeva
Jeanette and Todorov film theorist
Christian Metz and sociologist Jean
Baudrillard
Umberto Eco and others from abroad also
occasionally lectured at the center
so with this kind of intermingling of
communications theory in structural
linguistics with elements of Marxist
critique you start getting a rican Sep
xual ization
of the of the notions introduced by
jakob s'en so if we consider the case of
roland Bart and his 1961 essay the
photographic message which appeared in
the journal communications on the
service it displays faithfulness to
Jakob s'en interpretation of saucy Aryan
linguistics in terms of information
theoretical senders receivers and codes
as Bart explained in the opening lines
of the essay quote the press photograph
is a message considered overall this
message is formed by a source of
emission a channel of trician
transmission and a point of reception
the source of emission is the staff of
the newspaper the group of technicians
certain of whom take the photo some of
whom choose compose and treated while
others finally give it a title a caption
in a commentary the point of reception
is the public which reads the paper as
for the channel of transmission this is
the newspaper itself in contrast however
to the founders of French post-war
French structuralism Bart began to twist
this analysis to propose a kind of
historical and ideological critique of
language according to Bart in the same
essay every code is at once arbitrary
and rational recourse to a code is thus
always an opportunity to for man to
prove himself to test himself through a
reason and a liberty in this sense the
analysis of codes perhaps allows an
easier and sure historical definition of
a society than the analysis of its
signifies right so code had effectively
designated for information theorists an
efficient mechanism of taking a message
condensing it and transmitting it in a
way that would be resistant to noise
right part of what we start seeing in
the work of Bart and some of his
colleagues at the center during this
time it's an attempt to conceive of code
as a set of historical and possibly
political determinations that are
structuring the speech and the
activities of the people who are using
the semiotic
in this way you you gradually have a
kind of theme it ization of a certain
technocratic presumption that was always
underpinning the introduction of
semiotics of cybernetics into the human
sciences under the auspices of the
Rockefeller Foundation and the Ford
Foundation so rather than simply
rejecting this model right there's an
attempt to begin reworking it into begin
reworking information theory from within
rather than overturning or rejecting
cybernetic methods outright this
semiotic analysis turned increasingly
towards the problem of decoding on one
hand this meant an analysis and
explanation of codes convert the
governing communications such as in the
press photograph but also meant a new
effort to strip away the code
structuring everyday life as well as the
celebration of these aberrant methods
aberrant methods of decoding that might
reveal a kind of hidden ideological
content of communications right and this
kind of attempt to continually rethink
what language and communication is
through a kind of differential or
critical reading of information theory
if in Bart's work at least the kind of
reaches its apex in SZ right we're in I
said among other things what does he
suggest a concept of the read early
according to which codes can proliferate
inside of a text and that rather than a
text being about communicating one set
of efficient meanings from an author
kösem cells can begin to multiply write
and rather than trying to eliminate
noise from communication noise is
something that is produced by a kind of
active creative reader
while strategically retaining concepts
of coding code encoding redundancy and
communication Bart effectively redefined
the opposition to efficient effectively
redefine them in opposition to the
efficient procedures of communication
engineering the flight from noise which
organized cybernetics and information
theory was here inverted the read early
in narrative text staged a noise that
was no longer confused or erroneous
cybernetics was instead reduced to a
science of properly and orderly encoding
to orthography while semiotic sin its
evolving alliance with Marxism was a
science of the improper and errant code
of what Bart here termed a cog Rafi
these commentaries of Bart which were
paralleled by remarks by honoré Lefevre
dairy and cambium precipitated a final
and decisive turn against cybernetic
ambitions in the course of the early
1970s the project of enacting social
reform through cybernetics research
championed by the Rockefeller Foundation
championed by the Ford Foundation became
an object of critical investigation by
critics including Baudrillard Deleuze
and Guattari on jean francois leotard in
his essay requiem for the media from
1972 Jean Baudrillard
directly attacked communication theory
as a vehicle of contemporary oppression
and accused Jakob s'en of its
propagation quote this theory is
accepted practically everywhere
strengthened by received evidence and a
highly scientific formalization
by one discipline the semia linguistics
of communication supported on the one
side by structural linguistics by
information theory on the other end
quote in this account communication
theory became a vehicle for erasing the
historical foundations of a particular
economic modes
he took a model that was intended to
efficiently communicate an industrial
resource communications telephone
conversations and you transpose to under
general model of what man was quote the
entire conceptual infrastructure of this
theory is ideological eConnect
with dominant practice as was and still
is that of the classical political
economy it is the equivalent of this
political economy in the field of
communication that we witness here and
quote so what's to me most remark about
Bo jars reading here of communication
theory of structural linguistics as the
transposition of a particular political
economy under human sciences it's not so
much its status as a provocation not so
much its status even as a plumbing right
but rather it's actually a kind of
mundane factuality that he's observing
so clearly I mean it seems kind of
inconceivable that he would have known
for example the exact details of how and
why private foundations and private
philanthropies introduced cybernetics
and information theory into post-war
France right he certainly would have had
no idea how and why the CIA came to
sponsor the use of cybernetics by Livy
Stros in his reading group right but he
essentially looked at the surface of
what this communication theory was about
and tried to interpret what is its
meaning in being used in the human
sciences right but finally and the key
to it is he doesn't say at the end we
need to reject this theory because it's
somehow nonsense right but rather what
he says is that communication theory is
effectively political economy today so
what he ends up doing is embracing the
theory as revealing a certain truth of
what communications is that day and how
the human sciences were functioning in
this case around the early 1970s in this
sense it was not a false model
ill-suited for sociological or literary
analysis the model here it was instead a
kind of perverted model that accurately
construed the logic of a new economies
based on the systems of simulation and
electronic communication that was in the
rise and post-war France so at this
point want to try to kind of conclude
and wrap this up
and the broad picture what I see
happening here is actually a kind of
peculiar to the origins of the delivery
of cybernetics into France when
cybernetics arrives in the 1950s
particularly under the sponsorship of
the Rockefeller Foundation and through
Libby Stroh's it's seen as a way of
coming up with a kind of neutral schema
for binding the sciences for producing
interdisciplinary research and what
Libby Schaaf does he kind of neutralizes
Marcel Moses account of exchange of
gift-giving by suggesting gift-giving
more or less works on a kind of
cybernetic model right but in the course
of these readings what ends up happening
is the kind of understanding of
gift-giving that prevailed and most ends
up more or less returning within the
reinterpretations of communication
theory no longer about simply bridging
difference no longer about simply
bringing people together the fact that
communication itself is agonistic that's
involved in sets of competitions that
itself tends to spiral out of control
and that it provides a mechanism both of
organizing power in a society binding
people together but putting them into a
kind of combat these themes start to
come to the fore in the rereading of
cybernetics and information through not
because not because this is all about
all these theorists thinking about
cybernetics and information theory
rather a broader project of rethinking
the human sciences in the course of the
60s and 70s but what I what seems to me
so singular and specific of an enduring
importance about this kind of French
rereading of or this rereading of
cybernetics information theory in
post-war France is the way that rather
than simply rejecting cybernetics and
information theory it accepted it as
having a certain belonging to what the
Human Sciences were doing and it related
it to the fact that Communications
itself had become part of a particular
strategy in the sciences part of a
particular strategy for someone like
Deleuze and Guattari in psychotherapy
and so in this sense they allowed the
Human Sciences to be transformed by
cybernetics and information theory while
at the same time showing a critical
attention to ways in which this model
might be in a pro
in so doing what I think that really did
this is this is in the end why what ends
up happening among these theories is I
think more interesting than what happens
with someone like Gregory Bateson right
instead of simply allowing the Human
Sciences to be overtaken by cybernetics
what they end up doing is securing a
place for the Human Sciences to engage
the new technical Sciences engage
communication theory and at the same
time start developing their own specific
accounts of what communication is what
exchange is in a kind of post-war world
and so in a sense you can see in these
theorists a kind of early kind of
digital humanities or kind of digital in
humanities an attempt to move beyond
classical concepts of man according to a
critical reading of cybernetics not as
it was inappropriate to the human
sciences but rather according to how it
been imposed on the human sciences thank
you
[Applause]
it's kind of about you know harmonizing
Spears
the abstraction of the way civilization
workstation compared to close to the
piece
the texture of the patient's experience
and maths which really this kind of this
biographical detail which means
because you know this symbolic there's
always this this abstracting anyway
regarding the the other regarding uh
regarding the posthuman is part of it's
not it's not necessarily obvious here
but I'm partially actually trying to get
away from a kind of naive I there post
humanism or anti humanism right because
it seems to me what's a what's at stake
here is not at all a kind of rejection
of the human right and certainly I mean
if we look at if we look at the case of
Derrida
ones not at all done with the human
right but rather what the human is is
sort of being thrown into question right
and this is why it's important what's
important to me is that at the same time
Lacan is dealing with cybernetics an
information theory during the course of
the 54:55 lectures he also comes up with
this new term that he says would replace
the human sciences which he calls the
the conjectural sciences right the
definition of so-called man according to
a system of articulation right see that
again
I see you drive mind this quote here I
read this slightly differently I read
this parsley as saying you see this kind
of effort in cybernetics to oust these
concepts to overcome them but I don't
think he I don't think he quite comes to
the point of saying this is something
that has happened or will happen but but
rather there's a kind of refashioning of
what these concepts are going to mean in
an era of cybernetics and molecular
biology and so on I don't I don't there
if that completely deals with so it's a
kind of negotiated relationship to the
question of you know the human rather
than it simply rejecting it or
overcoming it I would think
and to Schrodinger with his life in
1942-43 and see also that as part of
this part of this move toward this
moment in terms of in terms of life as
as as in fact a cybernetic system of
code is excelent a system of information
but so you wonderfully depicted this
this thing that is happening in the
1950s and by the 1960s and 70s there's a
turn away from it nudity to that very
well as well yeah it seems to me and
what happens in that turning away from
it is then where cybernetics could
answer seemed to sports to some to
answer lévi-strauss of others to answer
all things for a certain moment it turns
out that we need to make distinctions
and one of the distinctions of
communication language specifically
another one of them another one is
information another one by the way will
be semantic content which in many
accounts will be separated from the
information from Shannon information
which is not necessarily about semantic
content but rather about correspondences
between here and here so in the midst of
all of that maybe kind of we come back
around to Derrida and they're not what
you didn't mention and talking about but
of course it was right there at the
bottom of the quote was Arthur writing
are sure and you know he's not he's not
parting he he is in a sense in
primatology reinstituting the universal
science
at the same time as other people are
sort of saying what cybernetics doesn't
answer all the things he's saying isn't
he
but I want you to comment on there's a
place of he's kind of saying no it
doesn't answer all things because you're
a bunch of Lobos interests and I've been
talking about his language and of course
that's not what the issue that's the
issue where cybernetics will intervene
way I the way I read at least is our
co-writing as a kind of impossibility
right in the sense in the sense where
he's he's he's developing this entire
history of it of a science that we based
on writing but at the same time
constantly pointing towards the limit at
which the science can actually describe
its entirety to describe the be mastery
of it's a master of its own discourse
right so within that I almost see the
ARCA writing as a kind of it's a kind of
figuration meant to hold the place for
something that must be there that we can
never actually quite name and never
quite actually get it right and so for
that reason I sort of located within
this attempt to critique the aspirations
of cybernetics information theory
molecular biology to develop a signs of
writing because ultimately the science
itself will always be impossible and so
the arc EIC kind of is a as much as
anything kind of structuring fiction
that makes sense
except except I'm wondering about I
think I think that's the Liberty market
way to innocence as a science of writing
in the conventional sense almost whereas
it is about the structures of all the
architrave
we
and on the other hand it seems to me
that what character was saying that in
the attempt to form a conversation
between these two out of this of this of
the two that the other one
yes of the
the the other side I think that is nice
Coco Coco seems to say exactly
it seems to me that
no no that's great I think so all that
means really really useful I think what
I'm trying to get at and this does
actually partially to Gary's comment is
I'm trying to sense - to see how I think
these theorists were actually moving
beyond a kind of simple matter matter by
their incompatibility or mirror theories
right because okay there is there is
this kind of no way
but merleau-ponty or even Chomsky is
saying could in a way be seen to mirror
or reflect what Shannon says this is
this is not about meeting this is not
about what humans are up to or we have
two different types of systems once a
kind of problems the communication
engineer which probably excludes
questions like semantics right and then
another is the problem of language which
can be coded and transmitted but it's
not the same thing as information right
so in that stage I think you have a kind
of potential sort of mirror theories all
right
well what what excites me about what I
saw what about what I see in particular
the con doing initially but I think also
developing and Dario in a different way
is to say actually there's a way in
which these theories belong to a similar
kind of fabric belong to a similar
fabric that has interrelated conceptual
foundations but also I think and this is
this is probably part of the better
answer to the to your question there are
key writing that I'm haven't totally
pierced yet right there's even something
like I said if common material
conditions that underpin these different
domains that tie them together but don't
quite reduce them to identity right so
that's what I'm trying this is what I
mean when I say there's a way which I
think these theorists actually say
secure a kind of place for a kind of
communication theory coming from the
softer kind of human sciences right
because in because they're actually
coming up with a different way of
theorize and communications that is not
subservient to cybernetics but is sort
of in dealing with it as a fact which
the humanities have to confront but gets
beyond the kind of two exclusive
positions model that's what I'm trying
to does that make sense you see I'm
trying to say
[Music]
thermodynamics you're right
this system why this thermodynamic would
pop up faith for two reasons one because
discovery of something that you cannot
there are things for it was designed
that's the moment in which the disease
Dexter we changed completely
I remember that at the beginning of the
70s very young scholar a motivator in
this young age circle about the or in
the circle the iconic as an example
which is not computer what was that the
margin that and the other was the
discovery of the creativity the social
creativity you cannot be watchful
you can because this is the other in in
[Music]
the picture the resistance of the
thermodynamics beyond the also in in
before and the very fact that in
disability models
it was bastard what happened in America
it was these two elements
so then so so to try and we could recap
that so part of what you're saying is
that if one was to sort of explain the
the ultimate decline in moving beyond
cybernetic models it's not simply that
they kind that they're critiqued or
deconstructed but they kind of run up
against a problem of say desire that can
mean so just me just to kind of spin off
that I think that would perhaps I one of
them would also suggest me to be their
way not kind of persistence of these
theories right because I also think to
me what's exciting about these theories
is a way in which there was an attempt
to very seriously engage a new set of
technological and scientific ideas and
rethink say what the humanities are up
to in accord with that right
and so when you point towards part of
when I would do this research part of
what I try to figure out is what exactly
are the what are the ways in which one
could do a kind of similar project today
right you know we're one for whatever
example grapple with say the status of
things like Twitter within our
contemporary political system right and
so I wonder if there may be a case where
some of these things that were not
computable in the mid-1970s I wonder if
there might be a kind of shuffling of
what
it can't be computed today like
according to for example big data
according to massive tracking of
behavioral systems is eternity plus
convenience this I would say I would say
humanity what is
yeah
in Seoul earlier
so I think so very briefly I I I agree I
think so maybe the way I would want to
put it would be something like there's
there's an effort to more or less
accommodate all these various sources to
a whole set of technical projects with
which he's increasingly becoming
involved in the 1950s right so maybe it
is maybe it would be better to say
instead of saying it's an interpretative
reinterpretation of Shannon's model
rather it's an attempt to take what for
example is coming out of the work in
Prague and to rethink it in the
frameworks suggested right by
cybernetics and information through does
that make sense there is one other
technical footnote
right but I think it's a very
significant footnote so there's actually
throughout the 50s
yeah Carson is producing works that are
in in one way or another working with
the information schema right so in 1960
is the big kind of publication that
comes out of this and gets so much
attention right
but itself it rests on a series of
research projects and publications some
of which were not actually openly
published throughout the 50s that are
that are are that are very I think very
explicitly working with information
theory and cybernetics so that what
you're seeing here I think is a an
attempt at kind of a grand synthesis
right but the grand synthesis that
behind this particular model you also
have to deal with years of research that
he's been doing in conversations that
he's been doing with his colleagues in
in Cambridge that's what I would think
[Music]
quantities work it's turned into a
different set of quality settings turned
into different
in verse 46 I should be seeking formal
way through substance versus
[Applause]
[Music]